so instead of doing snarky or crazy i
think we did a little bit of both we
actually
let's do let's do somewhat serious but
more interesting we have this from
entrepreneur.com
neural link could begin testing human
brain implants
this year says elon musk implants
grafted into the brain and spinal cord
seek to be able to correct paralysis and
cure alzheimer's no i'll just i'm going
to say this
dude the idea that we could neurolink
and repair the nerve damage from
someone's spine and like give them the
ability to walk
coolest thing i've ever heard but you
want to know what is also
very cool not as cool as helping those
who are paralyzed but up there
elon musk says nora link has wired up a
monkey to play video games
using its mind similar yes did he say
which game it was though
that's what i want to know i'm hoping it
was mario brothers probably minecraft
brothers marvel brothers like the
original not mario kart they're not a
we don't have the technology for martial
brothers the original original with
mario and luigi and you get to punch
bricks warmer you're fighting that's the
one where you punch bricks the one where
no no no no no no no no
super mario super mario super than mario
brothers right the first one's called
mario brothers right i'm talking about
that
we're actually fighting luigi yes yeah
yeah you're university each other
the monkey's playing a game where you
get a dude to jump on turtles and crush
them to death and punch bricks
that game is brutal you can't punch
bricks in super mario brothers yes you
can you headbutt them you jump
that's not true the animation is mario
jumping and raising
oh you're right and punching the board
through his punch
yes when he jumps his fist goes just
punches the brick nerd
so it's that's canon is he's punching
yes wow that's right
why do you think they give him punches
in later games i wonder how many people
get that wrong on like who wants to be a
millionaire oh for sure he's not bashing
his head people think he has he holds it
people also also think he's spitting
fireballs his hand goes up
no no i know he's throwing farts right
he's definitely throwing fire so in
later games
you can butt stomp and punch bricks
straight up like in in the later marios
he actually
can punch but in the original he runs
and jumps it's it's brutal game you're
running around as a dude punching bricks
getting high on mushrooms punching
bricks stomping turtles okay
game's crazy anyway anyways just talking
about the social conditioning of video
games
what is mario kart what's the subliminal
messaging
princess yeah yeah when you when you're
in listing they're like what video game
you played the most
and then they have like a unit of guys
in like call of duty and they're like
training for combat
and then they have people who said super
mario brothers and they're running
around kicking turtles and
doing mushrooms but okay anyway the news
the mushrooms are a telltale
the monkey things take a lot of them and
you take the mushroom and you grow
yeah well it's a reference to alice in
wonderland yeah
yeah and then going down the right yeah
a lot of people don't know that so the
mushrooms is referenced to us in
wonderland i'm going to eat a muscaria
it's the
white mushroom but let's get let's get a
little bit serious we have this
this is check this out check this out
elon musk teased that
neural link could begin implanting
computer chips later this year
quote number link is working very hard
to ensure implant safety
and is in close communication with the
fda if things go well
we may be able to do initial human
trials later this year
the statement came in response to a
comment from a user who asked him to
participate in human testing or who
asked
yes i was in a car accident 20 years ago
and since then i've been paralyzed from
the shoulders
i am always available for clinical
studies at neuralink wrote
hamoon kamai on the social network dude
legit hook them up
days before musk assured that neuralink
already has a laboratory monkey with a
chip implanted in its skull
you can play video games with your mind
said the owner of spacex
the short-term goal of neural the
nurling project is to solve brain and
spinal injuries
while in the long term it would seek
human slash ai
symbiosis i'm not entirely sure what
video game they're playing
they say it's not an unhappy monkey he
said during a talk on clubhouse
a new social media we know that is you
can't even see where the neural implant
was put in
except that he's got a slight a slight
like dark mohawk
the uh the billionaire who spoke about
space travel colonies etc
said he was playing mind they were
playing mind pong with each other
that would be pretty cool what's that
this is pong pong
yeah that's what i wanted i wanted to
figure out wow that means
that's rudimentary i'm playing mind pong
with you right now what
what if you can control control the
mouse on your computer click things open
things pull up videos
just by thinking it like you won't even
need a mouse pointer you'll just note
you'll just point you just click ever
you'll be clicking it with your thoughts
so i have i'm ready for ai to just take
over let's just guys
maybe they already take it take the keys
you know we we we already have shadowy
cabals that are running our country
so just give it to you maybe hand it
over let's just hand it over skynet
the t1 thousands let's do it what if it
happened a long time ago
what if we already yeah we're already in
there well that's also simulation theory
is uh so would you are you gonna get the
neural link jack
plug me in baby let's do it i'll plug me
right in no i wouldn't do it no way no
no
i don't know it's it's unless if i was
if i was in that situation
where god forbid and you know my wife
always hates when i talk about
hypothesis don't say that don't say that
you know yeah knock on wood right it's
eastern europe but yeah exactly
exactly he doesn't want me to do that
ever but sweetheart if you're listening
earmuffs were i in that situation
where i was paralyzed having been in a
car accident when you hear those
situations
yeah i would definitely i would totally
sign up to be one of the tests i would
absolutely do that just push your wife
it's like saying if you were cold would
you put on a jacket
i mean it's so obvious don't say that i
don't want to be cold you wouldn't ever
be cold
never again i don't mean interesting i
know but no you're exactly right that's
what
that's where i'm coming from but she's
like don't even say don't even say but
think about right now they're at the
level of pong
right well we were we were at pong
levels what 40 years ago 50 50 what was
it
what 1970s 70s yeah i think it was seven
yeah so about 40 or so years ago
we had pong come out now we have virtual
reality you know
skyrim and you know 120 frames or
whatever you've got a really good
computer
and you can actually go into vr worlds
and draw the bow and the graphics are
way better
not like skyrim has the best graphics in
the world i'll be honest but uh
video games have gone a long way where
is neural link video game technology
going to be in 40 or 50 years
are you going to be able to plug in and
then experience
like you were mentioning with the rex
that's ready player one and two that's
the whole
world is and they they actually get into
the morality of it how
for people that might be low income for
people in poverty
it's actually this is the main character
he grows up living in these like
trailer park in the midwest that for him
it's an escape
from the enwi of his his daily existence
that he's i know right right there
that's one of the sac words
that he's able to get into and now in
but in in this world you're
you know you're the star of your own
universe you can go visit castles and
nights and everything right you're
living in the slums everywhere
let's be real like you know i i run this
show
i've got a bunch of channels called tim
cast bunch of followers and awesome
people who watch
it's true i would still much love to be
i still play skyrim i just started i
started a new skyrim
run down some mods i'd i'd love to plug
in and just go to a magical world and be
some random dude throwing fireballs at
dragons man
that'd be fun we're gonna get advanced
enough where you can be game you can be
playing skyrim right now and still
having this kind of one eye is like
spazzing
you probably have like 17 videos you
probably have like 70 video games going
at once
and as you're having a conversation
yeah it's gonna allow us to all okay
assuming you're fine and
nothing bad happens all good because
you're probably gonna be fine um will
you get the neural link
if it seems to work and five years go by
and people start getting it and they get
like super human intelligence and
um interoperability yeah seemingly
i just no i because when i hear stories
about time mag
and when i hear stories about the the
money powers work together to ensure the
proper outcome i just don't i think of
all the ways that this could be abused i
think of all the
viruses that right not just from you
know the elite quote unquote but from
you know just any bad actors that want
to get involved with this thing or get
into this thing
you know could you imagine getting brain
hacked like it's a thing
please do not bring when you guys have
your brain chips by the way yeah
animals with your brain hacking though
well they have to implant the animals
too but you probably could
they can remote control cockroaches you
see that ew yeah so
they they uh they can remote they put
can put a thing on a cockroach that
affects its
sensory can you do a lot of them at once
because i can think about a lot of
people i'd like to send
they can remote create they can remote
control humans they did it
they did a test where they were able to
shift the sense of balance through
equilibrium
so what happens is so you have to go in
a certain direction so you feel like
you're falling right
and so you start moving to try and try
to compensate yup
and they were like they're laughing and
like you put on a headset or something
dude it crazy stuff is on the horizon
man back in 2011
i me me and some friends bought a
consumer grade
it's called an extra electro
encephalogram or an eeg i think it's
called
as you do a headband as one does yes
it's a headband and it's got a thing
that goes in your head and it measures
brain waves yeah right and so what this
is this is this is crazy we
uh opened up a program that can detect
the brain waves
and then we me and my friend we put it
on and you try to control
the wave to make it go up and make it go
down and it's like random
and we couldn't do it and i was like i
don't believe this is legit i can't
believe it works we gave it to his
sister
and she was like so you want to make it
go up and it went straight up and we
were like whoa
and she goes and now make it go down and
we went down and we were like whoa how
do you do
that and she was like i just thought to
make it happen like
and it took her no time at all to figure
it out what we wanted to do was make
a a mind-controlled drone but because of
the limitations of the eeg we had it
only had
two two axis uh accident two axes axes
yeah axes
axes so we could make it rotate and go
up and down and i was like that's all we
need
the problem if i put it on i could not
control it because my brain is like i
don't understand this
it would be like if you've never gone
skateboarding you stand on a skateboard
you're like you're gonna fall
so if we could actually get to the point
the technology is still easily available
if not it's been dramatically upgraded
in the past 10 years
but we we theoretically had the tech
because all you had to do was write a
simple code
to synchronize their existing consumer
technology showing the wave
going up and down with the function of
increasing and decreasing power to the
drone's rotors
and that was not through an implant you
just had to put it on like a headband
and you could make that happen and then
control a drone we
you you could theoretically think like
the the plan was this
it's all possible you would think to go
up or down it could go up and down and
then you would think to spin and it
would spin in one direction
so then you could like aim it and then
come down and then go up and then rotate
moving your body around like you think
that your hands
like that's how we move our bodies it's
a thought process right the weird thing
is though
we can feel ourselves when we move stuff
and when you grab
something you can feel its interaction
with your muscles like let's say you're
holding a bat or a sword
it feels like an extension of you
because it it
all of the senses in your arm it's
shifting the weight it's putting
pressure on this point of this muscle
this muscles tightening
and you can feel the weight and control
it and in fact humans do this with cars
there was i was reading that's that's
muscle memory where you're talking about
that that
once you once you've done it enough
times you don't think about it
but it's what i'm trying to say is that
some there's something different where
humans when they use tools
it becomes an extension of their body in
the mind the mind actually says i
understand this is here and how long it
is
the same thing is true with cars that's
why you some i don't know if
this is true for everybody but i was
reading when you're driving a car you
have no problem drinking when you're a
passenger in a car you're like
spilling and it's like hitting you
because you don't know what's going to
happen you're you have no control of the
tool same with hitting the brakes and
stuff right
now think about this it's like a car
sick when you're a passenger or not
you're driving
one of the challenges of controlling a
drone with your mind
is that you can't feel anything about it
it's all visual
so you're looking at it and in order to
make it do the right thing
you have to see it do it you don't feel
it like i can feel myself pick something
up i don't need to see it my brain
instantly understands and it knows the
weight knows balance
everything the drone i have no idea i
could not be looking at it i had no idea
what's going on
so it's it's it's all it's it's much
more difficult
uh i digress however the neural link
technology
is is i think a lot of people look at
that and
assume we have to have implants in order
to have this kind of tech
no we could drive a car with a headband
you you you theoretically get to a point
where we have multiple nodes and you put
a hat on
or a tattoo well i'm saying nothing
implantable
i'm saying literally like a wearable and
then it just can you know a wearable on
your head
a tattoo is permanent i'm talking about
a tattoo it doesn't have to be permanent
but i'm i'm saying you wouldn't need
that you'd get in your car you'd sit
down
and then there would just be a thing you
just you put it on your head and then
you go you drive well i get the neural
link
and it would give you the sensory
perception of the drone like it would be
able to feed into your brain what the
drone's experiencing
these so far are read-only it's reading
activity coming out of your brain not
putting anything into it
that's what the the the issue with uh
nora link is
it's it's what do they say it's read
only yeah as far as i know like when i
saw the pig
demonstration it was read only and the
monkey playing pong is read only like
basically your brain has no sensations
of its own right
you can't actually feel it that's what
it would you don't need to do you
anesthetize when you're doing
brainstorming
for for the actual brain organ itself in
order to get to the point where we would
be at risk
well you could be at risk for in a lot
of ways with an implant but in order to
get to the point where you could have
like
a video game in your mind you
experienced through neurolink we would
need
right writable technology i'm not sure
that's going to be possible
because everyone's brain is different
it's not the same code it's a very very
similar code but
it's they're all unique structures that
are that's actually that's
this we mentioned that's a huge thing in
ready player two where um the company
has to sign up
make you sign all sorts of waivers
before you get in and there's a 12-hour
time limit
um but then also that apparently uh
there's a lot of people that hooked up
to it that jacked in
and they just their synapses got
completely overloaded
and so they've had to try very carefully
to like make the companies like make
that make things go away
right uh totally spasmodic um
you know seizures catatonic don't ruin
the movie is it out it's not it's not a
movie it's a book no
this is the sequel to replay one yeah
ready player one was a book they made a
movie and now there's a sequel ready to
play ready
and so and it's really really good
because it gets into all this and but
they you know did everything they could
to try to make it go away and they
cancelled all the recordings of it
and you know they can bribe every
politician so you know there's no worry
about the laws or regulations because
they know everything about you already
because everyone who signed in or your
family members are signed in
you have blackmail on everybody can you
could you imagine there's like
uh you know elon musk has this factory
or this like warehouse laboratory
and then like deep in like level six sub
basement there's people like strapped in
against their will with like
neural link in their brains they're
happy no they're totally happy
no no no no no no no no they're they're
it's like you're see batman the animated
series where the people are scared but
smiling because of the jokers
yes that's what it's like they're like
it's like this weird creepy face
just walks up is everyone enjoying the
game everyone's happy
you're enjoying how is your how is your
ride in the tesla roadster is it going
well and you're like
the windows are impenetrable yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free if you want to listen
to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all next time
you